so we're very happy to welcome you to
Columbia University to celebrate our
newest Nobel prize-winner newest Nobel
laureate professor yo him Frank
professor of biochemistry and molecular
physics and biological sciences our
congratulations first and foremost to
Professor Frank who shares this prize
with Richard Henderson of the MRC
laboratory of molecular biology in
Cambridge England and Jacques de vache
of the University of Lausanne in
Switzerland I'd also like to acknowledge
your hemes wife Carol Saginaw in the
front Lee Goldman executive vice
president and Dean of the faculties of
Health Sciences and medicine at Columbia
University Medical Center whom I'll turn
this over to in a moment
John cotesworth the Provost of the
University
Richard Axl University professor at
Columbia and also a Nobel laureate and
Martin Martin Chalfie 2008 laureate Tom
maniatis who leads the precision
medicine initiative and also was the
chair of biochemistry laying Tom chair
of the Department of Biological Sciences
and all of you from the Columbia
University Medical Center and the
Department of Biological Sciences in
Morningside who are here to celebrate
this moment from his lab in the black
building at the Columbia University
Medical Center professor Frank was
previously the winner of the 2017 Wylie
prize and the 2014 Franklin medal for
the methods he devised to turn images
taken by electron microscopes of
thousands of individual molecules at
different angles into a finely detailed
three-dimensional representation allows
all of proteins protein molecules of
life to be seen
this is the extraordinary work that has
been recognized by the Nobel Committee
professor Frank joins more than 80 past
and present Columbia faculty members and
alumni over the years who have been
awarded Nobel prizes in a wide variety
of disciplines from neuroscience to
economics this year's prize is a
testament to the excellence of our
biomedical research which brings
together faculty members from across
both these Medical Center uptown and
Morningside Heights but today is
professor Frank's day and we are proud
to have him as our newest Columbia Nobel
laureate and let me just say personally
this is the kind of work that usually
dates back many many years and even
decades and so it's in truth something
that we share with many institutions in
the world of basic research and this is
something that we take as an affirmation
of what it is we do in academic work in
fundamental research a person who lives
by a desire to understand something
better in the world is driven to do that
and sort of selflessly pursues that to
the point where new knowledge has
developed that has a profound effect on
humanity so we take pride because this
is a symbol of what we do not always as
well as these individuals by any means
but we strive for that so professor
Frank congratulations to you on this
very special day now
[Applause]
[Music]
and now word from League Golden League
well I'd like to reaffirm what president
Bollinger has said also congratulate
Carol but as you said this is yokum's
day it's really extraordinary and very
special he will probably tell you that
at 5:18 when he was more or less
awakened he wasn't necessarily sure
whether it was the Nobel Prize Committee
calling or the dog simply blocking to be
walked but fortunately it was the former
as well as the latter dr. Frank has
really been a pioneer in the development
of car electron microscopy as you heard
a technique that provides imaging at a
level that previously was not possible
but what's really remarkable out him is
this combination of being a developer of
a new method that allows for pictures
and measurements that previously were
impossible but also the extraordinarily
innovative application of that method
initially to the ribosome which is the
cells factory and groundbreaking work
describing how the ribosome works at a
level that previously was not possible
papers in nature for example showing how
the ribosome works in the parasite that
causes African sleeping sickness and
leading to ideas about how that disease
could be potentially treated most
recently has worked with other
colleagues that
the Medical Center is focused on ion
channels the little holes in the
membrane through which ions traverse and
send the signals and make the cells
communicate and work together again
groundbreaking work dr. Franck was born
in Germany during World War two received
his undergraduate degree in the
University of Freiburg but a fair amount
of time at Munich did some work at
Berkeley and came to the US about 30
years ago to join the wads or
and all bein as he said people have
often contributed at multiple
institutions we were very fortunate to
recruit Yakima here in 2008 a primary
appointment on biochemistry the
secondary appointment of biological
sciences and is from his lab in the
black building and in collaboration with
the New York structural biology Center
he's continued to his groundbreaking
work been supported by the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute by the National
Students of Health and also by a
philanthropist including lynn shostack
whose gift of the cryo and electron
microscope has really helped us move
this program forward dr. Frank has been
a member of all the right societies but
in reality today's award takes
precedence over all of that I want to
thank dr. Frank's colleagues and
biochemistry who helped us recruit him
here who have helped him with his
research but again become what you've
done is truly extraordinary Columbia
club University Medical Center are proud
of you we look forward not only to
honoring your past work but also knowing
there's great work ahead important
questions to be answered and this is not
quite the beginning but we know there'll
be a number of extraordinary
accomplishments and discoveries in your
future so may have everyone at Columbia
club University Medical Center
congratulations
[Applause]
well then this is an extraordinary day
for me
very touching a humbling experience
because I know that so many new things
are discovered all the time and it's
sort of an the shots are very did the
odds are very long to to get me to this
place and he just really I'm supposed to
be brief in my remarks on only one to
say that I wouldn't be here without the
incredible support by very gifted
students that I had the privilege to
have with me and be able to train the
postdocs and students research
associates who all contributed pieces of
this you know immense puzzle and so I
really like to express my appreciation
to to Carol my wife for the long and
patient indulgence for for my absences
you know mental absences which now you
know how they have been spent and I'd
like to also since as tink Altman was
mentioning much of the time here in
America was spent at what's--what Center
what's--what Center was a very nurturing
environment and for quite some time I
was able to develop these his methods
but I'd like to say that the move to
Colombia was he was very instrumental in
me able to reach out and develop
contacts and friendships with colleagues
over departments across departments and
I was a also able to draw from brilliant
students that I was able to recruit here
and all together they moved to Colombia
was he wasn't was a milestone for me and
I'm very grateful to my colleagues
faculty colleagues to the Dean and
president for making all this possible
and we are we add in in an important
transition because many people want to
capitalize on this on this new
technology and so the support for an
instrumentation Center and cry and
facility is is extremely important to
make the dreams of many of the people
here come true and there has been a
wonderful support and there were
generous gifts that that have made
possible the acquisition of new
instrumentation so thanks very much all
around
[Applause]
well very confusing experiment
experience you know because we mentioned
this this dog we've been anxious every
morning because it's been waking up
earlier and earlier and and and today oh
I I was I was sure it's gotta be walking
up by the dog but instead the this phone
call arrived and then when the phone
when the phone rang I wanted to actually
be sure that Carol didn't dismiss it as
a crank call because I knew the
sensitivity of the date and so sure
enough there wasn't a Swedish accent and
then everything that followed so it was
amazing and all I could say over and
over again this this is wonderful news I
didn't know and anything else to say to
these people in in Sweden and they kept
apologizing for waking me up so early
[Laughter]
[Applause]